well we all need a little zen in our
lives right but how about doing yoga
while raising funds for local
non-profits our next guest emilia bruff
founded yoga for a cause as a way to
give back to the community and she joins
us today alongside rachel chez and
vermeulen from the garden foundation
thank you ladies for being here thank
you for having us so let's start with
yoga for a cause tell me a little bit
about it and why you decided to start it
up okay um
i used to dance on the show jubilee and
i had a fellow friend performer that
called me one day saying she was
diagnosed with breast cancer
and i wanted to do something didn't know
what to do
and my birthday is 9 11 and years before
that i had started it was kind of hard
to celebrate on 9 11 so i started just
inviting people to come take yoga with
me on that day
and then i was driving and i said what
if i did something and called it yoga
for a cause and raised money to help her
to help her with the surgeries and being
out of work for so long and that's how
it started that was 2015 when it started
and this will be our sixth year that
we've done it and i choose a different
cause each year and sometimes a
different location and it's just grown
and grown and grown well congratulations
on everything and what a special way to
honor your friend and just raise funds
and you know kind of give back to her
and now to our community and i want to
bring rachel into the conversation how
does it feel to team up with your
foundation and yoga for a cause we love
yoga and we love having amelia at our
foundation so getting to do this as like
a fundraiser is so incredible and so
incredible for our clients who also love
yoga yeah so let's talk about the event
and when people come and do you house
multiple throughout the year or how does
everything work so usually it's one time
a year
it's on or around my birthday so it's a
way for me to just do something positive
on a day of such a tragic event so this
year will be saturday september 10th on
the lawn at downtown summerlin and i
usually invite all of we have so many
great teachers here in las vegas so i
invite a lot of the teachers who've been
teaching for a long time all the
favorite teachers to come and teach like
a round robin style class it's all
different styles of yoga we have vinyasa
kunilini hatha we have a big gong bath
we all my kunilini teachers surround the
field with our gongs and we do that and
we just raise a lot of money so
it's an 11 minimum donation ticks are
available on eventbrite and you can we
have a lot of awesome raffle prizes and
stuff available the day of the event
well that's incredible everything you
are doing and are all levels of welcome
sometimes
people are on their heads
bring your kids bring your dogs
bring you know your whole family it's
definitely a family evening it's it's a
very magical evening and i don't know if
you've been on the lawn at downtown
summer at night but they have all the
twinkle lights and it's just always a
way to bring the whole community
together for me it's not about
one studio it's about the entire yoga
community in las vegas and we're very
blessed here in las vegas to have the
community that we do well amelia rachel
thank you both so much for being here
we're excited to continue to support
yoga for a cause i love everything that
you're doing in the community thank you
ladies for being here thank you and
we'll just all live in peace
thanks amelia
jc all